i realized that i wasn't doing these
things as efficiently as possible and we
all know those people who
are super efficient and they just like
plow through every task and they do it
like my father is one of those people
you know when i started writing the book
i was
40 and i was like i have three kids i
have like a job i have all these things
that make me seem like an adult but i'm
still a disaster and like a hot mess and
i thought you know what
these people might be on to something
right but i also knew
that i didn't have it in me to like
marie condo my whole life because i
would dump the contents of my
closet and probably leave it there for
three weeks and get a divorce
so i was like i need little things that
i can do
small little step-by-step things that i
can implement almost without notice and
it has a huge
impact on my day and my life
i'm joined by erin's i met rudy erin
welcome to the show
hi chris thank you so much for having me
thank you for being here
are you gonna teach us how to adult
today is this an adulting seminar
um a little bit i hope i am almost an
adult that was sort of the plan when i
set out to write this book that
by the end i might actually be an adult
so i'm getting there
at 42. well there's hope for us all yet
then
um life doesn't come with an instruction
manual and
upon reading your little book of life
skills i've
realized how much of the stuff you
realize kind of just emergently
it's like how to make your bed or like
how to properly load a dishwasher and
stuff like that
no one actually does teach you these
things so is it just a desire for you to
seek some advice from smart people that
have got the answers and then compile
them for yourself like a
how to be erin dot doc book
yeah i think um i think i did i realized
that i wasn't doing these things as
efficiently as possible and we all know
those people who
are super efficient and they just like
plow through every task and they do it
like
like my father is one of those people
and at
you know when i started writing the book
i was 40 and i was like i have three
kids i have like a job i have all these
things that make me seem like an adult
but i'm still a disaster and like a hot
mess like rolling or rolling around with
like
i mean you know my car is anyway i'm
just i was a little bit of a mess and i
thought you know what
these people might be on to something
right but i also knew
that i didn't have it in me to like
marie condo my whole life
um because i would dump the contents of
my closet and
probably leave it there for three weeks
and get a divorce
so i was like i need little things that
i can do
um small little step-by-step things that
i can implement almost without noticing
right like just little things where i'm
like huh this is a small thing
and it has a huge impact on my day and
my life
um and so yeah so i was like i let me
set out to find
um best experts for each of these
individual tasks
which you know range from like waking up
in the morning um
to making a great cheese board to
sending a proper email
to helping a friend through a crisis um
and then you know there's a ton of fun
stuff there's folding a fitted sheet of
course doing laundry which i was
terrible at
um and just doing it in a way that felt
like i would do it you know what i mean
this is a book that i could read
somebody like me like you don't have to
go out and like
buy a million things to try to redo your
life it's just like
small little hacks little things with
big rewards
how hard is it to find a world expert in
folding a fitted sheet
um it well you know there's a lot of
them um out there there's a lot of
different people and
sort of why i wanted everything
collected in a book
is because you can sit there and google
like how to hold a fitted sheet
and then you wind up with like 400
videos and a thousand different
instructions and then you're in a
wormhole
on you know you're on instagram and
you're in
chrissy teigen's comments and like four
hours later
you're like what was i thinking what you
know and that can be fun trust me i
spend quite a bit of time in the
comments section on instagram
but i just wanted something that was
like handy and like a
and just just the facts um so for
for my laundry when i went to somebody
who started a business based on like
sheets and bedding and
she she has this company called
parachute home and she's pretty cool
so she was my expert for that so it was
fun that was a fun part of writing the
book is like figuring out who
the expert was um for each one
so a perfect example of this i keep
coming back to it a lot
to do with good podcasts is um
going to a museum or like an art gallery
so you don't
necessarily go to the art gallery
because the curator of the art gallery
is a good artist
you go to the art gallery because the
curator is able to select
people who have particular skills and
talents and an ability to present
something which you're going to find
interesting and you put your faith in
the curator
to select it appropriately a bit of this
and a bit of that and a bit of eastern a
bit of western a bit of modern bitter
blubber
i don't know what um but they
you know you you have your faith in them
and it kind of seems a little bit like
as you say you take the take that top
filtering you know if you can get
anywhere close
to the top five percent in the world in
anything they're probably at least 50
better than you are so like you don't
100
definitely definitely
what was the biggest hole
in your adulting game before you
started this book what was the weakness
you know like when you see your kids
they'll have like fifa and the players
will have like attack
defense speed or whatever what were you
worst at
out of the sections in your book um
that's a really good question i think um
other than just like really mundane
stuff like doing laundry which
my mother never taught me so that's her
fault um
[Laughter]
my children will leave my house knowing
how to do laundry um
but uh i would say the thing that i love
most uh that i that i have i've really
implemented a lot is like taking a deep
breath
taking a beat and not plowing through
everything
um that was something that i just felt
like i needed to like get stuff done get
stuff done
instead of like okay like let's calm
down for one second
and figure out the best way to do x y or
z so i think there's a lot in the book
about
um taking a beat just being mindful of
how you're doing things even if it's
grocery shopping right like
i would there's a good example like i'm
somebody who would maybe make a list
go into the grocery store definitely
forget the list
walk through decide i wanted to make
something different for dinner and oh
and then
and then get home and realize that i
forgot like half the things i went for
and like like i'm an adult you know like
i shouldn't be that was fine when i was
like in college
and you know walking through the grocery
store with a bag of chips and a diet
coke and like
but um it was that that idea that like
come on like that's a waste of my time
then right like i got i i need to
and i and we all could use more time to
just
or or you know just being able to do
these things
properly gives you a sense of like peace
and calm
and also um you know it doesn't stress
you out then like you shouldn't you
shouldn't have to leave the grocery
store like in a tizzy
right so so that's something that i
think um
was a big hole of mine and just like
slowing down a little bit and
doing things more mindfully even grocery
shopping
it is weird that you're dependent on
your parents and then you start to get
your independence
maybe sort of 13 14 you want to maybe
make breakfast for yourself and
i want to spend time with my friends and
no mom i don't need a lift after i've
been at football i'll get myself home or
whatever it might be
but then you're still perfectly allowed
to not know how the oven works and
like just all of the life skills that
you really need and then
you arrive at 18 or 21 i guess which is
like the last bastion of
some stuff to get over when you're in
america
and you still not learned them and then
you're like well it's okay
i'm 21. no one really expects me to have
my stuff together
and then you get to 30 i'm 32 you get to
30
and you're like okay this is this is
quite embarrassing now
like why is it so admission that
everyone that's listening will know my
mum still does my washing
i'm 32 years old and my mom still does
my washing
um my argument is that it's a good
excuse for me to like make sure that i
have to see her every week
and she does it better than me and but
there's part of me that thinks
for [ __ ] sake christopher you are
three decades on this planet and you're
still not doing your own washing
you know um yes i do know and i will
tell you
at i'm 10 years older than you and i
often will send
my my parents live not far from me and
when
i have a particular tricky stain or
something my mom
because my mom loves it she loves doing
laundry she just does
and i will occasionally just be like hey
mom like
it says hand wash and i don't hand wash
things like can you do it
i'd love to do that yeah but when are
you going to become your mum
because also i can't do diy my dad likes
hopefully never
but you get my point like there has to
be a point at which you
look to your kids the way your parents
looked to you
um and my mum and dad's skill set
like maybe on technology stuff they're a
little bit more deficient than me
but in almost every other area of life
they wipe the floor with me
yeah yeah i agree i i do think that they
have
less uh distractions maybe
you know what i mean um right so uh but
yeah my parents
are they're they have their stuff in
order my dad is like
knows he does everything the right way
you know and he takes such pride and
like
whether it's rolling up a hose you know
like he'll come over to my house and i
will have just watered the garden and
um my hose will kind of be not properly
put and he's like all right
oh my gosh i'm gonna show you how to do
this and he takes the time to unwind the
whole hose
squeeze out all the water make sure
there's no kinks and then really do it
and he just enjoys doing things properly
and it's such a nice thing to see
and i i do try now like um
gretchen rubin is one of the experts in
my book and she has something called the
one minute
rule and um if a task takes one minute
or less
to do just do it right whether it's
answering an annoying email or winding
up a hose
or um you know putting that dish from
the sink into the dishwasher just do it
and i'm trying
really hard to do that because it does
it does feel good
to do things the right way right so like
when you eventually do do your own
laundry like you're gonna feel like wow
i did this
you know and i do my own laundry now i
mean i have three children and a husband
and myself and
we all like play sports and work out and
so the laundry is
insurmountable most days um but
i do it you know and occasionally i
am proud of myself for actually folding
it and putting it away that's the hard
part
um and laundry trips everybody up
there's there's very few people on this
earth who are like i am
alone yeah yeah
my expert is an amazing laundry queen
her name is queen mama and she's
incredible her name's what
clean mama mama like clean mama she has
a huge instagram following and she
believes that you should just do one
load a day
like every day just start your day by
throwing a load in and then you never
have to have what i had behind me when
we started this podcast which was a
mountain i want you to put away
um and it just becomes part of your
morning routine
and that's sort of a big theme in the
book is like
you know having systems like that that's
something that i i didn't have
really let's get started chapter one
wake up and get ready for the day
what were some of the things that got
you ready for the day that changed
the most like getting out of bed is
quite hard
so that is one of my favorite pages in
the whole book
um and it's that idea of you're lying in
bed and you just think like i just want
to lay here a little longer or i want to
hit my snooze button
um but this expert dr bruce michael
bruce um
he says you just you have to just swing
your legs over just get your legs over
the side of the bed
plant your feet on your floor and like
you're halfway home if you can just do
that then you're supposed to take five
deep breaths
just to like get your brain like get the
oxygen flowing to your brain
um and drink a full glass of water
because and this is kind of
gross but interesting you lose a liter
of water in the humidity in your breath
in night during the night um so you want
to rehydrate
um and then this part has been huge and
it's been a game changer for me
is to get outside into the sunlight
as quickly as you can after you wake up
like within the first
15 to 20 minutes and that's because we
have this like melatonin faucet he calls
it in our brains
and the sunlight will stop that and
it'll wake you up and you'll feel less
groggy
for the rest of the day um and i try to
do that as often as i can like i did it
this morning i got up and i got outside
and
um that was huge and part of your
morning another thing is to water your
plants before the sun is really hot
so you can kind of combine the life
skills like you don't want to be
watering
your plants in the middle of the day
because the sun
can it'll evaporate that water and when
it evaporates the water on the flowers
it can burn
the flower so you want to water before
it's really hot
so i combine those two life skills i go
outside to get my
sunlight and stop the melatonin drip in
my brain and then i also water my plants
um and that is just like has been a game
changer rather than just like
laying about in your bed and like as
good as that feels
we've all done it and then don't you
feel like crap the rest of the day
and like your eyes are puffy and so it's
always better as hard as it is to just
get your ass out of bed as soon as you
wake up the best thing that i've heard
about hitting the snooze button is that
pressing snooze
is like saying i hate waking up that i'm
going to do it multiple times per day
i love that that's so true exactly
exactly
because it does i mean it's not always
fun but it's one of those things that
definitely you know
you don't regret like no one ever says
like oh i really wish i had just hit the
snooze button and laid in bed all
morning and gotten up
two hours later i mean no one ever said
that so
yeah i love that one uh blend the
perfect smoothie how do we make a
perfect smoothie
are you a smoothie person um i am a
smoothie person
and what i love about this one is um my
expert catherine mccord who has this
awesome
relicious brand she talks about using
frozen stuff
as like it's just better than fresh like
a lot of times it means you can get
really good organic frozen berries like
in the middle of winter and
not to be afraid of frozen right like
you think i have to have all this fresh
stuff
um i love she has this one hack of using
frozen cauliflower in um in her
smoothies
and it's because it has like really good
protein
and it doesn't change the taste of the
smoothie at all and it
makes it creamy um so it gives it like a
nice consistency which i think is great
um she also talks about using like
little extras like
collagen peptides um which is really
good for
our skin and our nails and our hair
um but just this idea of she talks about
a smoothie being like
meditation in the morning like it helps
you set your intention for the day
so if you start your day with a smoothie
even if you're gonna wind up eating you
know fried chicken later like you
started your day of the smoothie
right but if you start your day with a
smoothie you also kind of feel like
all right like i i just had like you
know five
servings of fruits and vegetables um but
i love that i
love her and i love like trying to start
my day with a smoothie because you know
you never know where it's going to go
from there but at least you started your
day with this movie right
you've got um laura vandecam past modern
wisdom
uh guest the happy ologist she was
phenomenal
when she came on so how do we get out of
the door in the morning calmly and
without forgetting anything
um let me look at that chapter because
that's a tough one for me the
funniest thing is after laura and i
spoke and she's a she's a friend i've
worked with her for many years and i
adore her um we did our interview and
then
i got in the car to take to go somewhere
and i was like sitting in my car and i
was like oh wait i don't have my keys
or my wallet like and i was like i was
like oh shoot like i
so um clearly i'm a work in progress um
but i think this one is so important and
it's there's no like great secret it's
basically just
put [ __ ] where it belongs and leave it
like always have your things where they
need to be
right so if you're leaving the house you
know that your wallet is always here and
you know that the umbrellas are in this
spot
and you know that you know so you're not
in a tizzy saying oh my god where are my
shoes or where is this or where is that
so
giving everything a home is really
important and then
taking again taking that time to put
everything back in its home
and it's just that like closing that
loop makes such a difference because
i think part of what makes it so hard to
get out the door in the morning is that
we don't know where anything is right
we're suddenly like
ah like where is this where's that but
if it's always in the same place
and you've designated this place and
you've told everyone who lives in your
home
where these things are and where they
belong and help them
put them back there then you always know
where things go right
and the other thing that she says is and
i love this i'm just going to read it
the space between putting on your shoes
and backing out of your driveway is not
zero
so many people think it is and that's
why they're five minutes late everywhere
you know we like i'm often late because
i think like oh i have to i it takes me
10 minutes to get there so i'm going to
leave here
10 minutes before i have to be there
i'll walk out but like you know and and
you always like walk outside and you
realize you you know you see something
at a pickup or whatever
um so leaving five minutes early is like
definitely key and then in terms of
forgetting something which i love
if there's you know say you packed
leftovers for
lunch the next day put something that
you don't want to forget with that
you know like put your keys or put your
keys in the fridge next to your
leftovers right because if you took the
time to pack up your leftovers and you
want to bring lunch so that you're not
buying crap or whatever
and in the morning oh wait where are my
keys oh yeah they're in the refrigerator
or you make a note you know you can make
a note to yourself
but like putting things together um
and yeah i just i i love her and i love
those ideas but it's again it's just
having a home for things and putting
things back away
which is trips everybody up but closing
the loop
is really important like the zeigarnik
effect is one hell of a drug man
if you leave that open loop for the rest
of the day there's just ambient anxiety
just pervading the source code of
whatever you're doing with the day so
yeah i'm all a part of that i've lost
three sets of keys in the last 18 months
um and
i have to change my front door lock
today or tomorrow
um and i couldn't even get out my own
house so i lost my keys but my two
housemates didn't
so i've been using my own back door to
get in and out of my house because i
couldn't
so i mean that's that's a i i just need
to read i need to ring laura and say
hi laura look can you please for the
love of christ can you help me
uh how about sitting properly in your
chair sitting is the new smoking kelly
sterett says
so let's try and restrict how much
damage we're doing
oh um i love that um sitting yeah
sitting is
is an interesting one um i love what my
expert says here which is in order to
sit properly you have to stand properly
first
so you actually have to like get up and
it's like stacking
um it's like stacking blocks so you get
your feet kind of planted properly
and then you want your hips over your
feet and then
you're you know it's sort of like if you
do like yoga or thanks thing about those
things and then
your shoulders over that sitting back
and then you sit down
um but if you think about it and i'm not
sitting properly right now
and that's the other thing that he says
i was like you know you're gonna forget
throughout the day
right but even a few times a day you
readjust and you kind of like sit there
and you know pull the thing up from your
head and sit like that but it's really
about
thinking of your body like stacking
blocks and your feet
then your knees over your feet and your
hips over that
and then sit down and try to like hold
it and core having the core muscles
helps
um you know our cores are all i've taken
a hit during quarantine but
um at least my ass but having core
muscles helps and just kind of like
keeping them engaged throughout the day
so that you're not slouched over
the idea is not to slouch over
constantly
or even like that you know so i love
that one too
it is becoming conscious of your posture
and you're right you're not going to sit
with that perfect buddhist
meditation cross leg blow this [ __ ]
all day
but every time that you notice ah no
hang on i'm not i'm not sat up straight
so if you're listening to this and you
sat down somewhere check your posture
right now please sit up straight we are
not
we are not a community of people who
have slouchy backs this is a
an upright well-postured podcast
audience that we've got going on here
uh make your point heard how do you make
your point heard
oh um that is another
um another really good one the
part of this that i found so interesting
um
my expert talks about having a point
first and so few of us actually
do we're just you know we're just
talking to talk or
we don't know what our point is so
making your point heard the first step
is making sure you have a point um
and yeah i mean who knew right
um and he talks about getting in and
getting out right
like don't don't use um something called
adjectives where you're just like oh
this is a great idea it's excellent it's
awesome it's amazing
like those are all good things to
describe something
like you wouldn't you would want to be
affiliated with something that's awesome
and excellent and amazing
but it's not really saying anything
right and you're just kind of like
filling the air
um and people and also um
when you're making your point once
you've made your point like just
try not to just keep going because
people remember
what you've said at the end of you know
um they're gonna remember like the last
few bits of things you said right
so it's like that idea of
let it lie let it sit there let it land
don't fill the air it's so we're so
tempted to um
like i'm doing right now it's it's a a
big confidence thing
and i've noticed it in myself especially
upon doing the show
um anyone that goes back and listens to
like episode 1 or
any of the first 50 which i can almost
not bear to hear
i don't have the confidence to finish a
question with a blunt point
i say a thing it's like setting off a
firework i set off the firework
and then it goes bang and then goes like
and makes this sort of weird there's
just so this is this this thing
isn't it do you not think about that and
it's what what was that what was that
you asked the question
like just [ __ ] leave it you don't
need to say that you don't need this
weird like post-coital pillow talk
after you've asked the question like
just say the thing so i i totally
totally get that and obviously as well
having a point like a lot of people
want to feel like they need to
contribute everyone that's been on zoom
this summer knows what that's like i
can't i can't leave this conference call
without saying something
don't you if you have nothing to say you
absolutely can leave this zoom call
don't say anything like saying something
which means nothing
is worse than not saying anything at all
absolutely
so i'm i'm all in joel you your expert
for that
is uh joel schwartzberg he's incredible
and um yeah and we we often dilute our
points
to what you were saying like we dilute
them by saying things because people
remember the last thing you said
so
zip it zip it um organize your work day
from uh nicole lapin who has seemed to
recognize her name i'm not too sure why
um she is amazing she's written a bunch
of books she's very cool
um and this one i love what she says
about um procrastinating
she's like you have to procrastinate
like it's we all it gets a bad rap
um but look at your work day and say
what do i really have to do today do i
do i need to do these things
because if you can push them off to
tomorrow or even later it frees you up
to do the things that you really have to
do today
um and i like that idea of um
you know things that aren't time
sensitive push them off um she also
talks about mark twain and like eat the
frog
the idea of like you know if you have to
eat a frog it's best to eat it first
thing in the morning and if you have to
eat two
it's best to eat the biggest one first
right so just
do the hard things early in the day when
you have the energy and also like
noticing
when you have we all have different
rhythms but like a lot of us are most
focused in the morning
um a lot of us feel kind of draggy in
the afternoon
um and also which i love too is like
often people will put meetings on their
calendar for 30 minutes 45 minutes or an
hour but if a meeting's only gonna take
like 12 minutes like just
you don't need to fill the rest of that
time with chit chat or what people are
watching on netflix or
you know whatever it may be now we're
doing so many zoom calls it's very
different
but she also talks about like walking
meetings you know like
can it can it be solved in a phone call
like we really need to sit in this
conference room
and get our snacks and go to the
bathroom and you know there's so much
wasted time throughout the day
um but i think you know organizing
organizing your workday that benefits
your own cycle is really
um it's huge and it's something that
i've like learned like if i can get up
and get emails out like before
you know nine o'clock in the morning if
i can send 10 emails or whatever
i'm feel like amazing i feel like
superwoman
but if i don't then it's like that leads
nicely into
how to stay on top of your email inbox
everyone this summer
will have had to play the hugely
upregulated email communication game
so what's the best solution for staying
on top of emails
um this one's sort of like staying on
top of the power curve right like
not getting behind so you have 15 emails
to respond to the second you wake up so
just
my expert there is justin kerr he's
fantastic and he talks about
just finding little snippets throughout
your day in between a meeting while
you know someone's dealing with
technical difficulties on a zoom
like and fire off an email get it out of
your inbox you know
um but i think the most important thing
that he
talked to me about is writing a proper
email and he says
the reason so many people work late and
too many hours is because they don't
know how to write an email and he said
you should start with your conclusion um
then say you know we're taught in school
like intro then supporting evidence then
our conclusion
um no like frilly like hey how are you
it's like so you know
all that kind of stuff like get right to
the point um
use white space use bullet points use
building
and remember that people are often going
to be we might write it on our big
laptop but people are often going to be
looking at it on
their little device and so a subject
line that
is to the point i think like seven words
or less so that it doesn't go over
you know what you can read um
and reply all which is like the death of
everybody right in our email inboxes
like nobody likes reply all so i said to
him i was like oh
cool so then because sometimes i won't
reply all just like side text the person
or i'll
email just the person back but he said
you actually do want to reply if you're
put on
a message you do want to reply all
because
then everyone else is going to sit
around and say like oh chris didn't
kristen didn't chime in here like i
wonder what oh is he
what you know what's his deal what's he
going to do and then you're kind of
making other people waste time
um but that said if you're the sender of
the email
think long and hard who you have to cc
like only people that need to be on that
email
should be on that email and if something
is going back and forth like way too
many times
take it offline like pick up the phone
walk to the person's desk
um don't let it go on and on and on
but i like that idea of just finding
like tiny pockets of productivity
throughout the day
and firing off some emails uh
today i was on my way to physiotherapy
session in an uber
and i did i went from maybe 15 emails to
inbox zero in like 20 minutes
you know like i got nothing else to do
i'm sat in the back of this uber
i don't know whether you guys have it in
america at the moment but in the uk it's
plastic screens in between the driver
and me so i can't even
i like it i like a a silent uber driver
i love a nice silent taxi ride
um so i got a bit ben shapiro podcasting
my ears and before i know it i'm like
i've just
done something that would have taken me
20 minutes of home time
and i've done it on the way to physio so
yeah i'm i'm all in for that
this one really intrigues me create
secure passwords that you'll actually
remember
like this is one of the most challenging
things even with a password manager
like because you the challenge with a
password manager like one pass
or lastpass um is that every so often
you'll be on a device where you don't
have access to that thing
and if you can't remember yeah it's
great to have a repository of them that
are kept safe somewhere
if you can't remember it there's this
low-level anxiety that's like
what if i get logged out or what if i
lose my access to my password manager
like i'm
that's got my life in it and then you
have a breakdown
yeah um i i love this one too i thought
it was so interesting
um coming up with one
base password that you use for
everything
um one phrase one word whatever it is
and making that kind of like
um there's there's things you shouldn't
be able to find it in a dictionary
it should contain special characters and
numbers um
a mix of uppercase and lowercase at
least 10 characters
um and it can't be you know guessed
based on who you are
you know not a birthday or whatever so
once you come up with that
like say it's password and it's always
the capital p
and you know an exclamation mark
whatever it is and you have to remember
you have to just remember that it could
mean something meaningful to you we all
have one right like i have one that i
that i know and then you just they talk
about just tailoring it so if you're
getting on
i don't know what do people get on like
ebay you would do
password at the end ebay um
password you know target
password uh zoom whatever it is like so
you
so whatever you're logging into you're
gonna use that same base password
and just the little exchange for
whatever it is that you're logging into
so you're only really having to remember
the base password because i have a
different password for everything
i i swear i think it takes up like hours
of my week
having to reset my password for
everything
but if you can come up with one really
solid
password that you use for everything and
then you just tweak the end of it you
know for
whether it's whatever you're logging
into and you know that that's what
you're gonna add at the end
um and it really i mean it works it's
pretty cool but you do still have to
remember that one base password so you
got to think of a good one
yeah no i i agree it's um passwords are
such
i think that password managers have got
it about right
but it doesn't feel like as seamless of
an experience as it should
do so there's there's definitely some
work to be done with that it's the same
as apple's iwatch or the apple watch or
whatever it's all right but it's not
quite there so
i'm excited for like password managers
in five years time that's what i want to
be
i want to be in that world um what about
getting organized
at home like i i'm pretty good at
decluttering
i think but it's something that can
mount up pretty quickly so is there a
is there a scientific method to
decluttering or is there something else
some sort of formalized process
well i think yes there is
um one thing that i love that
several experts mentioned is setting
timers for some of this stuff
so i think we put off a lot of
decluttering or cleaning or whatever
because we
think it's got to be some really long
marathon cleaning session right
but if we just say our junk drawer for
example
we all have that junk drawer that's just
piled with like
can barely open it right if you say set
your timer for 15 minutes
um and my junk drawer expert is shira
gill um
she's out in san francisco she's awesome
and she has these 15-minute wins
and you just dump the thing you sort it
out and 90
of what's in a junk drawer is junk or
doesn't belong there right it has
another home
so going back to that idea of laura
vander cans of putting things in a home
having a home for things
so you can quickly sort through and get
rid of like the
marker that doesn't work and the you
know the old band-aid or
i mean i don't even know what's in mine
right masks like it's all sorts of weird
stuff
and put it where it belongs right throw
the rest of the crap
out because most of its junk and get a
couple dividers put things back
in there and she talks about rebranding
the junk drawer
as not calling it that calling it a
utility drawer
um and using it as your own personal
general store
so curating the things that are in there
so you might want a little
screwdriver a little hammer um some
pandas whatever it is
um but rethinking it a little bit uh and
i love i love that one and i have used
that one
for sure um and then
peter walsh um is my decluttering guy
he's
fantastic he's so cool and he talks
about
when we're looking at our stuff we have
to not we have to think it's about us
right it's not about the stuff it's
about
us so we might look at something and say
like
like of course i have to keep x y or z
because of what it's like no you don't
you don't have to keep
anything really like you have to really
kind of look at yourself and say
why do i want this thing why do i need
to keep this thing and he talks about
two kinds of clutter
and one is memory clutter that we hang
on to like an old trophy or an award or
a pen that we got from a job and
or a trinket our mom brought us back
from spain or whatever it is
um and we hold on to that stuff because
we feel like it connects us to that
person or you know i i had this little
thing
that my mom brought back for me from
alaska and i
i couldn't keep it any it was just kind
of in the way it was just a little i
don't know what it was i'm sure she got
it at the airport
and i felt terrible i love my mother i
don't want to throw it out or donate it
but it was driving me crazy and it was
always in the way it had no place in my
house
anyway don't tell my mother but i got
rid of it finally after talking to peter
walsh
but then this other type of clutter is
um
i'll use it one day clutter right like
all the things we keep for some like
imagined future right so it could be
like skinny jeans that we
may never fit into again or um you know
a random piece of lumber that we think
we're gonna like suddenly turn into like
a cool cheese board like
my dad saves scrap like he'll be at my
house doing something and he's like well
you can't throw that out aaron
i'm like it's a half a brick i mean what
am i like
you might need it to you know what i
mean like it's like no that's clutter
i don't need that um and so if your
clutter causes you anxiety
if it's if you're hanging on to it and
it's causing you anxiety
just get rid of it and i think that's
what's was so interesting with him is
like it's not just about keeping your
house clean and getting rid of stuff
it's really about like
looking inside and figuring out what you
want for a space you know is it supposed
to be
a really zen room is it supposed to be a
creative space
and thinking about what you're going to
get out of it instead of what you're
going to put into the room in terms of
like
pillows and curtains and ottoman you
know
so that's changed my approach and now i
can like ruthlessly throw stuff out in
my house
there's people out there who live this
minimalist movement that's kind of quite
big at the moment where i think the
one of the approaches is to have 40
items
like 40 possessions and that includes
clothes
and that elon musk just sold all of his
possessions because he thinks they're an
attack vector
uh like james altucher who's also been
on this show
um he lives out of literally lives out
of a suitcase sold all his houses just
rents places now
picks up a suitcase and like unbelie
like
you know there's some smart people so i
think you know if james altucher and
elon musk can do it then there's maybe a
little bit of hope for us as well
right let's get into this is like the
meat for me make chores
easier this is kind of this is real
adulting here how first off
how do you load and unload a dishwasher
and secondly
why did you have a different expert for
loading it and a different expert for
emptying it
were they specialized is it is that how
specialized dishwasher
technique has become um i guess so
um i had consumer reports do how to
load a dishwasher and they're like this
organization
in the us that like you know
tests out products like they test it out
i think
um i think they test something like let
me say like 300
dishwashers and they send like hundreds
of thousands of things through it
during the year and coming up with what
works and what doesn't and what do you
have to rinse it first or do you not
have to rinse it first
um and so i use them for how to load a
dishwasher and loading a dishwasher and
a lot of us in quarantine
who share homes with you know friends or
spouses or whatever
um have learned that everyone has a
different way to load a dishwasher right
and i mean i this morning our dishwasher
didn't
didn't
run last night a glitch and so i woke up
like
dishwasher was full but i took that my
husband loaded the dishwasher last night
but i took that opportunity this morning
and i was like
there's like potatoes on forks and like
actually like the smoothie glass was
like caked with some like there's no way
that was gonna get clean
right so i had to take it out and we
rinse it um
but it's all about like loading things
in a way
that it's going to actually maximize
getting it clean right so you're not
supposed to put dishes
um touching really you don't want that
can create watermarks
um you want your glasses on the top
uh your plates on the bottom you know
you don't want to put things kind of
willy-nilly
and with with um with your utensils you
obviously want to put the forks
with the fork up you probably know that
right knives down
um and not putting i always thought you
should put like
you could put all your forks together
all your spoons together but you don't
want to do that because they can nest
you know like they can wind up next to
each other like your spoons could spoon
you know and then they won't get clean
um
so you actually do want to kind of mix
it up a little bit um
which i think is really uh was kind of
interesting
um and then you know just kind of
knowing your machine but for emptying
the dishwasher
i loved my i love my expert names rachel
hoffman she
you should totally check her out she has
this movement called unfuck your habitat
um and it's basically like for people
who don't really like to clean but
you we all have to do it right and so
she has all of these great little hacks
um and her this the first step for
emptying the dishwasher
is ask yourself what you're going to do
with the next four minutes of your life
like are you going to cure cancer like
if you're not you should probably just
empty freaking dishwasher and get it
over with right because it'll hang over
your head
all day and then you wind up just using
it as like a cabinet right you walk by
and you're like oh
not in a bowl and like that is so not
adulting at all
meanwhile the the sink is filling up
right i mean we've all done it we all do
it
um so just like and she says again
set a timer and you'll realize it
doesn't take that long and then with
that
and i love this it's just take all the
plates out and put them right on the
counter next to the thing take all the
bowls out
like get everything kind of stacked
neatly and then take it to the cabinet
rather than going back and forth and
like like
you i could i had no system before this
and now i kind of look at it but the
other thing
that i learned and i didn't know this
is you're supposed to empty the bottom
rack first
always pull out the bottom rack first
and it's because the top rack
often has glasses that or bowls that can
flip
and they have the gross dishwasher water
on it right and so you open the top rack
and all that water sloshes out and gets
on your clean plates
and i always used to find myself like
frustrated while i was opening it i
didn't realize why but it was because
like oh there's sturdy water
but then if you have the bottom empty
pull out the top rack you can just dump
it
have a dish rag dry it off and put it
away
um so that's one that that i think is
kind of cool and rachel hoffman's
awesome but it's really just about like
just
do it you know like do your future self
a favor and get it done
right and i i don't always do it but i
try
i get it right my mom's gonna kill me if
i don't ask this one how do you do the
washing
oh um well
that one again we talked about clean
mama and she's
fantastic um but she wants you to just
choose one load a day like do your darks
or do your sports clothes or do
your delicates um so that way you feel
like you're conquering like
one thing a day and you're getting it
done
um don't over stuff the wash or the
dryer so many of us do that
you should be able to put your hand in
and kind of like move it around
um because if we you know if you put too
many things in the wash it's gonna
they're not gonna get clean same with
the dryer um
and i think one of the most important
things
for me and for a lot of people i know is
forgetting that you put something in the
wash
and not moving it to the dryer so and
then it's like
what do you do you have to re-wash it
it's going to be gross so setting a
timer
if you have to so that you know to go
back and get your washing and put it
into the dryer
um is kind of important and i love like
she talks about using baking soda
as a hack if you have like really kind
of like stinky stuff or odor like things
that are not coming clean
um and just using that in the wash
um before using some of that right in
the drum
washing it and then washing it again
with your detergent
and not using not using um
fabric softener or dryer sheets or any
of that kind of stuff because it really
like breaks down
the the clothing um but yeah so i mean
it's like again it's taking
a little bit of time shaking the stuff
out putting it in there
when you're doing um sheets and towels
you shouldn't put your sheets and towels
together um because they're
different completely different materials
right um and you should always
like often in the dryer you wouldn't
know this chris but your mom knows like
the
the sheets get like wound up in the
dryer right and you take them out of the
dryer
and they're twisted and weird and then
they're not quite dry
so she says you just pop open the thing
halfway through and kind of like
do that with your hands and then then
it's done
you come out and you have dry clothes
rather than things that are wound up
into balls
um so that is kind of good but it's
really i mean doing the laundry
for most people what trips them up is
putting it away
you know it's actually like again
closing that loop like you have the
clean basket of laundry now just
quickly fold it and put it away and
that's about like put on music
put on a podcast put on netflix
make it more pleasurable like make it
something you want to do like you know i
have a lot of friends who
only allow themselves to watch like
below deck on bravo or whatever it is
like some silly show
if they're doing laundry right so um
then it becomes something you can like
look forward to if
i had to watch below deck whilst i was
doing laundry the laundry would be done
in three minutes flat because i
absolutely hate that tv show um
if you're doing your laundry while
you're listening to this as well drop me
a dm because that would be really funny
send me a photo of your laundry and i'll
be able to pass it on
be able to pass it on to iron and say
look we helped some people through the
laundry
um how do you tidy a room in 10 minutes
or less because that sounds that sounds
like the sort of thing that i want
in my life um okay
tidying a room in 10 minutes or less you
first you want to set a timer
so that again um it's something you feel
like anyone can use 10 minutes right
anyone can spare 10 minutes to do it
um and you want to look for the things
that will smell first so like dirty
dishes
garbage laundry um and take those to the
places where they belong um
and you want to look at flat surfaces
and clean flat surfaces first so like
your desk or your dresser or a
countertop
and it's just because visually we our
eyes go there and if we see a lot of
like
crap on a counter it just kind of
stresses us out right and then you feel
like oh well
that's a mess i may as well just throw
more like mess be gets mess um
and so cleaning one surface and then and
this is rachel hoffman again from unfuck
your habitat
and she says then leave the room
and then come back in and look at it and
the first thing that catches your eye
in a bad way just deal with it just go
do it
you know like i'm out of the corner of
my eye i see i have a peloton bike and i
have two
pillow shams that have been drying on it
for longer than i care to admit which
means i haven't been on the peloton in a
few days
but it's been bothered it bothers me you
know subconsciously at some at a certain
point but still it's like
i i have two pillows on my bed that i
could easily put them on
so when we hang up i'm gonna go do that
in honor of tidying my room because it
is it just starts to like
frustrate you but and then you can
always do add another 10 minutes if
you've done really well you can just be
like okay that was easy i'm going to do
10 more minutes um because you can
realize that like these things
don't have to be i think that's why a
lot of people
avoid laundry or avoid cleaning because
you think oh it's going to take me
all day like i need to get in the right
headspace and i need to like put on my
cute outfit and like my work my work
stuff or whatever like that's how i used
to be
instead of just doing it i would like
put it on my to-do list and be like okay
i'm gonna make a cup of coffee and then
i'm gonna do it it's like no just bang
it out get it done
moving on one of the main reasons that
people procrastinate
is that they have a lack of information
i.e they don't know
how to do something um or that
what they're doing um requires more
information than they've got
so they need to ask someone how to hang
up a picture or fold the laundry or do
or whatever
um but hopefully if people have managed
to glean some of the skills that we've
given them today
that they'll they're getting over that
inertia to go do the task it's not as
daunting
when you when you know the answer to the
question answering the question becomes
quite easy
so hopefully we'll have helped people to
get past some of that inertia today how
about
prepping for cooking dinner like cooking
dinner
is always going to be a little bit
different based on what you eat but
preparing for cooking dinner seems
pretty ubiquitous how do you do that
um it does and this is rachel ray who's
you know a big big chef here in the u.s
and i'm sure you guys have
heard of her as well she's a big deal
she has a show and she
does these like 30 minute meals so she's
like the perfect person
for prep for cooking dinner um
and she talks about always mentally
running through what you're gonna make
no matter what it is um so
walking yourself through the recipe from
beginning to end because so often
we'll get to the end of the recipe and
realize oh we don't have you know
cream or whatever it is right so and
that's where that a lot of that angst
and frustration can come from
so get yourself through there relax
pour pour augusta wine pour a cup of tea
um
put on a tv show you really like make it
so it's a pleasurable experience like
prepping for dinner
shouldn't be like just churning stuff
out not really thinking about it it
should be something that you enjoy
so that you want to do it again right um
and then getting everything out getting
everything out that you're gonna need
so that way you're not like dredging
chicken you have raw chicken on your
hands and then you have to go into the
refrigerator right we've all been there
and then you have like a gross hand
print on your refrigerator door
and you're like yeah finding all the
pots and pans
setting it up this doesn't take long
either and she has she uses something
called a garbage bowl
which i love and just putting a big bowl
out where you're prepping
and rather than having to go back and
forth to the garbage can you just use
that for your scraps like whatever
vegetables you're chopping put it like
put all the garbage in your garbage bowl
and you can empty that as you go
but then you're not walking back and
forth and she really talks about what
you want to be
you don't want to move around a lot when
you're prepping for dinner you really
should just be in one spot
so it's getting a big cutting board
getting your garbage bowl
having all your pots and pans out having
all your vegetables ready to chop or
whatever you're making
in the order that you're gonna do it um
whatever's gonna take the longest you
start there
um and just like trying to enjoy the
process a little bit and that's
what a lot of this is about it's not
like that we want to rush through all of
these mundane tasks so that we have more
time to
you know watch tv um it's it's learning
how to do these things properly and
taking our time with them because this
is life
right our our days are made up with
sending emails
and prepping for dinner and tidying our
rooms and doing a load of laundry and if
we can do those things with a little bit
more confidence
and um skill then we can
kind of feel good and have these little
wins throughout our day
and at the very least they're not gonna
you're not gonna be frustrated and start
cursing while you're emptying the
dishwasher because you just dumped dirty
water all over it you know what i mean
so
um it's this idea of just setting
yourself up taking a beat to like
set yourself up to do the thing properly
i really like that i like the fact that
you identify
that life really is made up of these
little things it might look on instagram
like there are some people out there who
are just
constantly in santorini like having
cocktails
but even they need to change the kids
nappy and they need to go to the
bathroom
and i gotta dry my hair and you know
there is a
laundry list of [ __ ] that everyone needs
to do
each day and if you can work out the
right way to do it the most optimal way
to do it i think your dad's quote was
something like
um do it right first time and you can't
do it right first time if you don't know
how to do it
but if you do know how to do it the task
actually becomes super easy
you don't need any more information you
don't need any more utensils
because you've done it a million times
before in precisely the same way
and you know where the utensils are
because they've got their home and
that's where they live and so on and so
forth
i'm looking down here at some of the
stuff like thankfully because
still i'm like a man child these aren't
things i need to do
but like plan a cocktail party how to
set an impressive table
um arrange flowers in a vars iceland
arrange a cheese board my business
partner would love that
um uncook a bottle of wine and taste a
bottle of wine like this
it really is quite a uh quite a guide to
adulting
i'm gonna try and pick one one more off
the end in fact is there anything
toward the end like to finishing the day
or upping your interpersonal game or
your
your personal game are there any of
those that really stood out to you that
you've taken yourself
that you absolutely loved there anything
that you want to finish on
um i do love um
i do love this idea of reviewing your
day
every day um and it's like at night
you kind of go back and look through
your day and see
what did i do right what did i do you
know what could i have done better
i wish i hadn't you know sent that text
or i wish i hadn't
um you know i wish i'd gotten to the gym
whatever it is but
this idea this comes from patty
morrissey and she's um
just a really cool person who talks
about being
kinder to ourselves like that's really
like something we all
can can do right and especially during
quarantine
um just taking a minute and looking back
at your day
in a way that you have like
patience with yourself gratitude we're
not looking back to be like oh i screwed
up i didn't empty the dishwasher i
didn't do this properly i didn't do that
properly
um but just saying okay like tomorrow i
want to try to do
you know i want to try to get up out of
bed this morning maybe i didn't tomorrow
morning i want to try to get up out of
bed
um looking back on the way you did
things and saying okay
tomorrow's a new day uh and i'm gonna
try
a little harder to do this or that um
but i try to do that a lot because
obviously like i'm trying to implement
all of these life skills and there are
some days that i really crush it
and other days when i really don't um
and i think that's
hopefully that's why i wrote this book
and why people will like this book
because i'm not
this perfect person who's sitting here
saying like well this is how you do this
and this is how you do that
i'm basically saying look i am figuring
it all out too
um but now we have all of these
resources telling us exactly how to do
these things
in a really easy way that we can all do
like this is none of this is
none of this is rocket science right it
really isn't i mean even making the
cheese board
that was a game changer you should
definitely try that it is incredible
marissa mullen is my cheese board expert
at that she's
that cheese plate and she's phenomenal i
mean my friends literally
are it's a running joke because i will
make a cheese board
for everything like if someone pops over
for like five minutes i'm like oh i'm
gonna make a cheeseboard
three-year-old's birthday cheeseboard
for the three-year-old
100 yeah yeah it's so fun
um but yeah but looking back and just
being kinder to ourselves and
and you know trying a little bit harder
but um because
you know again because it's it's our
life and it's like if you can have peace
and calm and a sense of efficiency
and like my dad says like do it right
the first time because then
you're done you know like then you don't
have to deal with
going to fine key and i'm the same way i
lose my keys all the time and then it's
like you know oh now i have to go deal
with that
and we're adding things to our to-do
list when we don't actually do them
properly the first time
absolutely if in a world where we've got
too much stuff to do
adding more on is a surefire way to make
life
miserable so yeah i'm all i'm all for it
so the link
to the little book of life skills will
be in the show notes below of course go
and pick it up on amazon
anywhere else that you want people to go
erin any other stuff you want to plug
online oh yeah they can follow me on
instagram i'm doing all sorts of fun uh
posts and trials of my of my attempted
adulting
um and i'm i'm at aaronz ruddy on
instagram
um and you can hashtag the little book
of life skills if you want to try
something yourself
and uh and we'll we'll see how we can
all start adulting a little bit better
because
we can still learn even at 42 you know
there's there's always new things to
learn which i love
awesome thank you so much for your time
aaron thank you so much chris this was
so fun
[Music]
you